ayer y soya arroz hoy pollo con ensalada
en los últimos meses surgieron en los
barrios más pobres de buenos aires
muchas ollas comunitarias como esta y
por la necesidad en el trabajo y hambre
por eso venimos a la comida lo que sí no
realmente se hicieron los trabajos
realmente no vamos acá
a los asistentes habituales se han
sumado más personas necesitadas como
fátima una empleada de limpieza que a
raíz de la pandemia perdió la mitad de
su salario y que por primera vez en su
vida acude al comedor con su tupper para
ella sus tres hijos y su nieta solo
todas las novedades del hombre nos
llegamos porque no se gasta comer coca
para que comenzará una nueva vida y no
comenzar anoche o comenzaba anuncios
medianos los niveles de inflación que
hoy vive argentina de un 52 por ciento
afectaron los ingresos de los ciudadanos
y según datos del instituto nacional de
estadística el índice de pobreza general
se ubicó en un 40% en el primer semestre
del 2021 nunca tuve la necesidad siempre
tuve trabajo y bueno y ganaba bien
después de la pandemia fue donde no
conseguía trabajo y hasta el momento
todo lo días mandó currículo y no me
llama sin embargo los expertos coinciden
en que la pandemia sólo aceleró procesos
que ya estaban en marcha en el país como
la multiplicación del trabajo informal y
el aumento de la inflación